without warning in the middle of the
night
myanmar's military made its move
here an np's family captures the moment
soldiers arrive at the house
pre-dawn raids the first confirmation
it's seizing power de facto leader
and along with the country's president
are among the officials detained a coup
in all but name as myanmar's military
announces a state of emergency
the state of emergency is in effect
nationwide and the duration of the state
of emergency
is set to one year
this man commander-in-chief min outline
is now in control
he was previously sanctioned by the u.s
for alleged human rights abuses
against the rohingya today he was seen
on state tv
meeting the man now appointed acting
president
the military refused to rule out a coup
last week as it reiterated concerns over
alleged voter fraud in november's
election
which and sang-soo chi's party won
decisively
with a new parliament due to start this
morning it took action
we are still in disbelief that this
happened and honestly we really don't
know where this coup will lead us to
for me personally it was my worst
nightmare unfolding right before my ass
the atmosphere in april is eerily calm
as we're awaiting the arrival of an
imminent storm
in yangon military supporters celebrated
the move
as worried residents cued at cash points
after phone lines and internet went down
for hours
while in neighboring thailand protests
outside the embassy got heated
with myanmar migrants and thais
demonstrating against the generals
undermining democracy
so they can do whatever they want to
they have gun they have weapon
all we have is like we show our feeling
that's it we can shout but they can
shoot
again the military controls the streets
it previously held for more than 20
years
in the past clashes between the people
and soldiers have resulted in civilians
blood being spilt this rogue move by the
country's generals
has put myanmar at a dangerous and
disturbing crossroads
siobhan robbins sky news